this is something a lot of people don't
know but when you were casting the film
I know that it really got down to the
wire between me and Chris Pine it's hard
why is that not plausible but you know
it was close it was tough and you were
like ah no one's really good-looking and
he's an amazing actor and then there's
this other guy who's older and very
feminine but I actually wanted to prove
that I could have been in that movie so
recently just before the movie came out
I met up with gal gadot Wonder Woman and
I showed her my fighting skills and I'm
gonna show them to you now and I think
this gets me into the sequel let's take
a look yeah block and deflect okay
things you can block bullets with those
right the thing was exactly baby they
can put in in post right now they're
going to put in bullets
[Music]
[Applause]
you heard it I'm cast I just got the
part that's great
you